Henry apasa is 15 years old his workday
starts at 10 in the evening he buys
packs of cigarettes and then resells
individual cigarettes
then okay I don't know but I have to
work so I can make some money for my
family so I try to sell as many as I can
Henry lives in Otto
a sprawling city right next to the
Bolivian capital of pots five days a
week he works the nightlife district in
the seedy bars and clubs he sells his
cigarettes for 25 cents apiece
sailes pickup is the night advances
Henry has to know where and where not to
go
there are lots of criminals in Hellas
door organised gangs and for me they're
the biggest danger Henry's been doing
this since he was eight so he knows the
territory and he knows about the police
if they catch him they'll take his money
away and his cigarettes
working children don't count for much in
Bolivia and what he does is illegal
Henry brings home the equivalent of
about four euros a night this is where
he and his family live lunch is rice
onions and chicken nine square meters
for four people and Rand is two sisters
and their mother Teodoro they have room
for two mattresses and a stove and not
much else
mrs. Apothic it's just 75 euros a year
and support from the state that's just
enough so that we have something to eat
every day all the children have to work
they don't have a father anymore
he left us that was seven years ago
Henry's tried to take over his role the
Apostles live in unit OMA the poorest
neighborhood of El Alto every day after
school Henry and his sisters take the
bus into town to go to work it's cold
and windy here 4000 meters above sea
level the population of El Alto was
soared to more than a million over the
past two decades as people leave rural
areas
Henry's younger sister Cielo is 8 she
sells sticks of chewing gum in the
restaurants downtown
hello and fourteen-year-olds Oh Selina
work for hours every afternoon some
people get angry and tell us to go away
they say we've been brought up badly
they don't buy anything and they don't
understand why we have to work the two
girls have made six euros it's been a
good day they buy a new stock at always
at Victor's kiosk
the pequeña to the current abyss I've
known the two since they were babies
some working children do well others get
into trouble and become addicted to
alcohol or glue olivia is the poorest
country in South America about 1 million
children work here they earn much less
than adults and have virtually no rights
so child workers have got together to
form their own labor union 10 year old
Carla collects paper and cardboard she's
a member of the Union wearing the
union's blue vest helps protect her from
attacks at night she earns 1 euro per
sack
Christiaan is also in the union he has
big plans
I want to buy new shoes and I want to go
to college Henry is a union delegate he
and his colleagues in the Union are
working on a letter to the government
asking it to enforce fair wages and
provide free medical insurance the union
wants to see child labor fully legalized
we got the government to change the
constitution it no longer bans child
labor outright only the exploitation of
children says I think let's put that
sure being a union activist has changed
Henry he used to live on the streets
like many other child workers and he had
a bad habit of sniffing glue drug
dependency is a major problem among
Bolivia's child workers
Veon devalue when you're high on blue
you don't feel the cold you feel light
but when it wears off you feel the
hunger in the cold again sniffing glue
did me a lot of damage
now he's sober and he set himself some
ambitious goals I want to run my own
company of a house and a car I'd like to
become an important person Henry points
out that socialist President Evo Morales
was also once a child worker